[Music]
the music reminds them of home but it
does little to lift the mood
in this community center in huddersfield
ukrainian expats fear for the relatives
they left behind i absolutely worried
about all situations what is now in
ukraine and my family all my family in
ukraine and
my mom in ukraine
be very worried and pray every day for
ukraine
not even galena's 11 year old daughter
is shielded from reality with russian
president putin looming large in her
thoughts i feel really scared frightened
about it because you don't really know
what to expect from him it's like any
time any second
and those words echo the feelings of the
community
spread across the uk yet desperately
checking news from home like sergey in
london whose parents are in northern
ukraine and don't intend to leave we
discussed with parents kind of water
supply communication supplies and
if the
mobile phones doesn't don't work so what
would we do
but still
probably
part
of
myself stays positive and
i keep in touch with parents
they said that they are
not going to leave
they have a cat they have a garden to
take
care of
nadia shares that sense of defiance
she's only visiting london for her
niece's birthday and even though her
family want her to stay in the safety of
the uk
nadia says she wants to support her
homeland i want to go home honestly i
want to go home
so this is like this is my country i
want to protect it i want to
to to show my position you know because
if everyone will go away from ukraine
then it's an empty territory and then
the neighbors can come and conquer it i
don't want to be a refugee i don't want
to
to go away from the from this hard
situation i want to be with my people
and i want to support and contribute as
much as i can i'm not a soldier but
anyway to be strong as a nation i think
it's important to be there physically
but for ukrainians in britain sleepless
nights over the fate of their loved ones
back home
continue milena vassalino sky news